oh damn I could really use a snack right
now how about you if you clicked on this
video I'm sure you must be hungry hey
what's that send you a value pack see
but I'm not just hungry for anything I
want that rare snack that precious tasty
taste that no one else has ever tasted
oh I could tell you why you know what
I'm hungry for I think you're gonna like
this okay how about this
forbidden strawberry ice cream when you
see it it will blow your mind
not just from tasting it but looking at
it
this will legit took me awhile cuz I
don't get it
oh my god I want to eat it it looks
delicious
you're not feeling a dessert okay
alright I understand
me neither sometimes you just want
something yes a suite that isn't
necessarily ice cream I got you fam only
two sweet calories one sweet juicy
choice how about some gummy bears no no
no no I made so num num num num num
still want them give them to me
give them I know there's soap but I
still want them in my mouth what do you
not understand I know eating them will
probably kill me
but I still want to put them in my mouth
what's so hard to understand about man
the real forbidden snacks I mean not if
you're a youtuber you can afford it even
me I'm like nah no they overcharge it
and I will not do it another forbidden
ice cream okay alright what could it be
it looks delicious Darth Vader's scalp
yes I do want to eat it why do you have
to judge me for it don't you just hate
when you're eating your favorite snack
and then someone else comes in and be
like and you're like somehow they have
soand your meal with their judgement
it's like they spit in it come on stay
for dinner we're having spaghetti well
if your wife made the sauce I'm staying
I remember when
I was younger I would eat noodles when I
came to home and my dad would he would
smell it and he would go yeah why do you
eat that garbage and I'm like but it's
delicious
but you just took away at least two
points on the delicious scale because of
your judgment and I want you to eat the
skull of Darth Vader then I don't need
your judgment
20:18 PewDiePie everybody what has
happened fisherman buddy of mine found
this magical guy no eating him it's
forbidden so yes sometimes I guess you
get these super rare what does it call
mutant sword yeah okay and you're not
supposed to eat them because they're so
rare but whatever anyone tells don't eat
it my brain just goes oh yeah so by
saying I shouldn't eat it I want to eat
it more it's blue it probably tastes
like bubblegum blue is lip color of
bubblegum it's a bubble gum Lobster
bubble gum lobster bubble gum Lobster I
don't care if I'm not supposed to eat
this is a no-judgment zone in this
channel we're an all-inclusive Channel
no judgment alive forbid and bacon
everybody damn you ever cut down a tree
and disco you ever slice a tree in the
many slices and no excuse
excuse me mr. tree but
I didn't know you look so delicious you
can taste it through the screen I want
to eat you treat now I don't know if
it's nearly approaching dinnertime but
I'm getting hungry a swimming banana
damn that's a sexy banana damn usually
you know people use bananas is some sort
of six you would think that's sexy okay
I want that in my mouth still looking
for a snack still looking for something
to quench your hunger all this works
making me really hungry I know just the
thing
have you heard of forbidden tuna that's
right everybody it's me you crack open
this can of tuna
you got a 100% chance of not surviving I
like those odds that's what makes it
forbidden and that's what makes it so
damn delicious can you imagine the tuna
that no one has ever eaten that's gotta
be so good are you still hungry okay
let's keep going guys
I put an orange on my cat and now it
looks like an egg and now I want to eat
it so it's a cat and an orange but does
it taste like egg cuz it looks like egg
many much tastes like trying to wrap my
head around this but it doesn't make any
sense
cats don't lay eggs I don't understand
this a name which way do you like them
Jamie another dessert tara misu
hmm that looks good that looks very good
what's that it's about a thousand times
my size has that ever stopped me I could
just have a slice I don't need the whole
thing all right I know why it's too big
for me but I'll just have a tiny little
piece of it forbidden
this one is classified as forbidden
that's how you know it's gonna be
forbidden ground me I actually thought
it would read ma that must be the flavor
of the beef red ma a mop flavored beef I
know it's a ma okay don't get me wrong
here I'm not stupid
I know it's a mom but does it taste like
beef hey where's the baby okay I get it
you're not into desserts okay you're not
into actual food okay you want a snack
you just want a snack I got you fam I
got you how about some Cheetos but
forbidden Tito oh damn that it's a
Chinese cheeto
ha ha ha damn that looks good mmm even
the dog he's giving me that look isn't
he he is I hear buddy you've done a lot
for me you can have a bite it one or two
bites but I'd say I want it in my mouth
I'm not gay all right but I want that
dog's leg in my mouth all right you're
it you're a tough one to convince all
right so no snacks no desserts no meals
how about just a simple soup huh
just a simple soup but of course we're
bathing suit that's right
how about listen you don't know if you
like it unless you've tried it how are
you supposed to know I think it's really
rude for people to disseminate against
others all right just eat him stop being
so racist just eat it
I'm getting really sick I'm not finding
the right food that I want to eat just
want a food I just want to food that's
forbidden possibly illegal and most
hundred percent certain they will kill
me is that so hard to understand all
right
okay fine how about forbidden Koh
how about some forbidden toast it
probably is Iraq it wanes just like a
rock
it feels cold like a rock it is
surrounded by rock but it looks like a
toast how about some cheese it will burn
your face off how about some shell I
don't care if it's Birds what about some
stick
here you go vegans have some skank
forbidden cheese steak forbidden
broccoli why is all the things I want to
eat why are they all fermented I guess I
will not have any I guess I won't eat
anything
I guess I'd rather starve it's not my
fault that I can't control my cravings
you and I grow forever suffer we will
never know about the wonderful taste
that our buds are being denied this is
actually a tragedy it's a sad story but
we must be strong one day we will eat
their forbidden food speaking of food
space lampshade the absolute mad lad ate
a picture of my face one of the most
delicious forbidden snacks for a hundred
days
[Music]
which means now I have to eat a picture
of his face yes that is how that works
smash like and I will do it in the next
episode of PewDiePie goodbye and check
out the merch limited time only meme
review merch if you're a 9 year old and
you want to flex it which of course you
want to do link is in the description I
see you guys tomorrow it's yummy time
[Music]